[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu einer spezialausgabe von 485
köpfe fünf meinungen seit zwei wochen
wird putins furchtbarer krieg russland
damit nach ukrainischen angaben seinen
truppen luftangriffe gehen weiter der
deutsche journalisten verband fordert
alle deutsch journalist auf russland
schnellstmöglich zu verlassen und die
angst vor den folgen des ukraine kriegs
hat den ölpreis zeitweise auf fast 140
us dollar pro fass getrieben das ist der
höchste wert seit 2008 experten halt
noch weit höhere preise für möglich wir
werden heute abend unter anderem darüber
debattieren ob deutschland die gas und
öl importe stoppen sollte meine gäste
heute abend der ukrainische botschafter
andrej melik bild politik chef jan
schäfer der stellvertretende
chefredakteur und für die nach acht
horst paul ronzheimer der uns wie jeden
abend live aus kiew zugeschaltet ist und
dessen informationen so wertvoll sind
weil er einer der letzten journalisten
chris ist und last but not least der
bundesvorsitzende der jungen union thema
kuba eröffnen möchte ich die runde gerne
mit den eindrücken vom pforzheimer paul
wie bei der heutige kriegstage was ist
hier passiert du warst vor ort
janina vielen dank dass ich auch heute
wieder bei viertel nach acht über die
situation hier die dramatische situation
in der ukraine sprechen kann ich war
heute mit meinem kameramann jorgos botha
fuß unterwegs bei ihr team das sind dann
vor ort von kiew ungefähr 20 autominuten
entfernt und was ich dort gesehen habe
hat mich wirklich nachhaltig schockiert
war an dem ort an dem gestern raketen
eingeschlagen sind
es war in der nähe einer kirche menschen
die schon alles gepackt hatten die ihre
koffer dabei hatten und die weg wollten
aus der stadt wegrennen wollten und von
einer russischen rakete getroffen
zivilisten es sind zivilisten anders als
putin das mit seinen lügen uns glauben
machen will diese stadt wird so heftig
bombardiert dass man sich vorstellen
kann was hier auf kiew noch zukommen
wird die zerstörung ist riesig und auch
als wir dort waren sind menschen durch
einen fluss an einer kaputten brücke in
richtung sicherheiten gerannt und sie
konnten auch dort natürlich keine echte
sicherheit finden denn es gab schüsse es
gab gefechte menschen sind dann nervös
losgerannt dort raus anders als ich
haben sie keine schutzweste oder ein
schutzhelm der sie vielleicht ein
bisschen schützen kann vor
raketenangriffen
und dann hat mich ein statement eines
jungen mannes beeindruckt oder zumindest
zum nachdenken bewegt der auch
ausgekommen ist aus alpinen aus dieser
stadt und der gesagt hat wie könnt ihr
das alles mitmachen warum tut ihr nichts
warum schließt ihr den luftraum nicht
warum gibt es keine flugverbotszone
und ich weiß dafür gibt es sicherlich
viele
geopolitische gründe die aus sicht der
deutschen dagegen sprechen würden wir
reden immer über die angst dass wir in
diesen krieg mit reingezogen werden das
mag alles richtig sein aber aus sicht
dieses mannes der gerade alles hinter
sich gelassen hat er sein board
vielleicht nie wieder sehen wird der hat
die frage an mich gerichtet warum tut
deutschland nicht mehr warum kann
russland raketen auf uns regnen lassen
und das ist etwas was ich heute
mitgebracht habe und diese schmerzhafte
frage auch möchte dass sie in der runde
diskutiert wird
ja lieber paul ich muss auch sagen die
letzten wochen waren absolut beschämt
ich habe mich teilweise so hilflos
gefühlt und habe manches mal gedacht ist
es eigentlich richtig teil dieses
politischen berlins zu sein ich habe
mich wirklich manches mal geschämt dafür
und genau bei dieser frage was tun wir
eigentlich diese frage mir auch immer
wieder selbst gestellt tun wir
eigentlich viel zu wenig wenn ich
gesehen habe dass es wochen lang
gedauert hat bis die 5000 helme die
alleine schon witz waren überhaupt mal
angekommen sind wenn es dann alleine
schon wieder sechs tage gebraucht hat
bis die panzerabwehrraketen und singers
in die ukraine geliefert worden sind das
teilweise dann anschließend bei den
nächsten raketen verschimmelte raketen
dabei waren dann frage ich mich
ernsthaft ob es das ist was wir leisten
können ich finde dass es zu wenig und
deswegen haben wir als junge union ja
auch dazu aufgerufen mehr zu tun was
würden sie mehr tun herr kuban wir haben
ja auch noch sanktionen verhängt die
deutsche wirtschaft ja jetzt auch schon
treffen genau seine sind ja die
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen das ist ja
auch richtig dass wir diese
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen machen wir
haben in erheblichen maße dort uns auch
bewegte ich glaube gerade am anfang gab
es auch noch ganz andere diskussion wir
werden ja auch noch mal später über das
thema embargo diskutieren aber es geht
auch um die frage was wir militärisch
liefern können was wir den ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer zur verfügung stellen
können in diesem brutalen
angriffskrieg von wladimir putin und da
glaube ich dass unsere bundesregierung
das eben auch unsere industrie noch
deutlich mehr liefern kann wenig sie
sind der ukrainische botschaft da wenn
ich sie jetzt frage was braucht die
ukraine an militärischer ausrüstung was
würden sie fordern also wir haben zwei
listen an die bundesregierung geschickt
die eine schon vor über einem monat da
ging es eben vorrangig über diese
luftabwehrraketen und anti panzer
raketen und sachen sowie aufklärung nach
sich geräte so ähnlich ist also die für
ausstattung für die truppen dienen und
die zweite liste erst letzte woche und
diese zweite liste sie beinhaltet schon
eine gesamte palette von von den
waffensystemen da sind auch panzer
gepanzerte wagen
auch flugzeuge und schiffe das ist alles
was was wir in der tat heute brauchen
würden denn ein panzer konnte als
offensivwaffen noch vor ein paar wochen
angesehen werden aber heute ist ein
panzer wenn ein ganzer das dorf von oder
gstaad ihn beschützen könnte von den
tschetschenen die dort jetzt ein teil
übersetzt haben und auch die umgebung
das sind brutalste leute deswegen auch
ein panzer in eine solche situation
könnte eine defensive waffe sein und
deswegen sind wir im gespräch mit
verteidigungsministerium mit der
industrie auch parallel denn wir wissen
dass die bundeswehr natürlich selbst
viel gerät braucht und das ist jetzt
jeder tag ist entscheidend für uns wir
versuchen gerade auch selbst mal zu
klären was auflage ist was die deutsche
industrie und deutschland ist ja der
viertgrößte exporteur von waffen was da
schnellstens geliefert werden kann mit
der unterstützung der regierung das ist
jetzt so dieses konzept das wir
versuchen auf die beine zu stellen aber
jeder zahlt jeder tag zählt und die zeit
läuft uns davon
der punkt ist glaube ich an botschafter
thema machen kann sie haben es hier mit
deutschland zu tun einem land das
eigentlich sich quasi entmilitarisiert
hat und ich glaube da kommen wir zum
kern des problems tema-q bahn hat ja
gerade angesprochen was passiert es in
den letzten wochen wie lange es gedauert
hat überhaupt 5000 helme zu liefern dass
systeme geliefert wurden die gar nicht
mehr einsatzfähig sind seit 2012 gar
nicht mehr benutzt werden dürfen
eigentlich nach unserem standard sie
sagen wurden dann nicht geliefert
treffen aus wurde nur eine zusage
erteilt von der ba von der behörde aber
das ministerium das zuständige hat gar
nicht die zusage erteilt das heißt diese
estrella also pfeilen raketen der
synthetischen herstellung sind immer
noch in deutschland ja aber es wäre
glaube ich auch schlimm wenn sie
geliefert werden weil man gar nicht weiß
genau sie dürfen hier würden ich habe
mit dem verteidigungsminister gesprochen
und das thema geschilderte sagte wenn
das möglich ist schick schick sofort das
was was einsatzbereit wäre aber es ist
noch nicht so weit also wir warten immer
noch dass diese entscheidung kommt und
auch wieder andere waffen geliefert
werden dann eine waffe einst in der
rakete könnte ein helikopter abschließen
das vorher vielleicht wohnhäuser bord
hat während aus der bundesregierung dass
es dass es heißt wir wissen gar nicht
welche waffen wir schicken sollen wir
haben das dilemma jetzt ja auch wieder
gesehen am vergangenen wochenende oder
in der letzter woche es ist einfach
nichts da und da kommen sie zum
kernproblem dieses land ist eigentlich
entmilitarisiert und wie wir aufhören
von einem hohen generieren die sagen wir
sind eigentlich blank was die eigene
verteidigung angeht wie soll man da
einem anderen land wie der ukraine
vorbei stehen politische abwägungen dass
man natürlich auch immer schaut auf die
reaktionen putins herr u bahn haben sie
denn dafür verständnis dass natürlich
auch in der politik darüber debattiert
wird wie wird putin reagieren auch mit
blick auf diplomatische verhältnisse
zueinander das ja auch manche nicht
komplett für lieferungen sind es geht
für uns darum auch klar zu machen wir
sind nicht selbst kriegspartei aber wir
unterstützen die ukraine wo wir nur
können und wenn ich mir anschaue was wir
beispielsweise den afghanen geliefert
haben was wir dort leuten hingestellt
haben die bei erstbester gelegenheit
sofort den rückzug angetreten haben und
abgerückt sind und die sachen einfach
übergeben haben dann frage ich mich das
kann nicht unser ernst sein dass wir den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer nicht mehr
erwachen zur verfügung stellen und es
stehen definitiv auch noch sachen zur
verfügung der botschaft der manic hat
gesagt jeder tag zählt und das gilt ganz
besonders für unsere bundesregierung wir
wollen nicht kriegspartei werden aber
wir wollen ja ihn bestmöglich
unterstützen
kann
ich ihn ja also das ist ja alles gut und
schön ja dass wir alles gut und schön
was die waffen angeht und das ist auch
ganz wichtig aber jetzt hat keiner
eigentlich auf die frage geantwortet die
mir der junge mann heute bei ihr team
gestellt hat nämlich warum gibt es keine
möglichkeit einer flugverbotszone das
hat ja auch der ukrainische präsident
angesprochen der sich sehr enttäuscht
von der nato und auch europas gezeigt
hat und die menschen sagen putin lässt
raketen auf uns regnen und die westliche
welt tut nichts es gibt keine
flugverbotszone man tut nicht um den
luftraum
ja zu befreien von russischen raketen
dort ist doch der grund wenn ich direkt
beantworten darf ich finde diese debatte
auch sehr sehr wichtig der grund ist
doch dass wladimir putin bitte
korrigieren mich wenn ich jetzt etwas
falsches wieder gebe aber vladimir putin
hat doch darauf hingewiesen dass wenn
die flugverbotszone eingeführt wird dann
sind wir doch eigentlich schon fast
kriegspartei oder nicht
naja das ist das was war die mir putin
sagt aber wladimir putin spricht viele
drohungen den ganzen tag aus
auch gegen deutschland gegen die
westliche welt und ich habe ja gesagt
ich verstehe durchaus
die argumentation und dennoch ist es
eine finde ich finde ich wirklich eine
schwierige eine schwierige frage und
wenn man sie aus der ukrainischen
perspektive betrachtet hat sie ja
durchaus
seine berechtigung
ja die frage ist natürlich berechtigt
und die auch die forderung von
czilinsky ist absolut berechtigt
nur für uns ist natürlich eine
abwägungsfrage wollen wir da können wir
kriegspartei werden oder können wir es
nicht werden und ich bin wir haben eben
gerade über die entmilitarisierung
deutschlands gesprochen wie hat deutsche
können dass am ende nicht alleine
entscheiden das gehört zur wahrheit auch
dazu sondern wir müssen es gemeinsam in
der nato entscheiden und wenn ich mir
anschaue dass wir 2015 auch in syrien
das ganze zumindest mal diskutiert haben
übrigens auch in spin in
diskussionsstand wo angela merkel als
bundeskanzlerin das auch ins spiel
gebracht hat weil eben dort gift
eingesetzt worden ist giftgas eingesetzt
worden ist und deswegen sage ich schon
es müssen am ende von seiten des westens
auch klare rote linien definiert werden
und klar gesagt werden wenn putin diese
roten linien überschreitet dann sind wir
auch bereit am ende eine
luftverkehrs nur verbotszone
einzurichten ein remake haben sie
verständnis dafür dass deutschland
zögert und die westlichen staaten mit
blick auf die flugverbotszone
ja sie haben selbst gehört das was paul
ronzheimer vor ort spürt und sieht also
die ukraine können das nicht
nachvollziehen auch mein präsident hat
das mit drastischen worten kritisiert
diese haltung wir glauben dass das auch
in ein messer in den rücken der ukrainer
ist dass man einfach sich durch diese
angst
quasi leiten lässt und dass die einzige
was entscheidend ist dieser drohung von
hand buchen und wie gesagt man man
könnte auch an drohen ja wir würden das
machen und schauen also was was
geschieht das heißt man man man putin
definiert ist das spiel und unter westen
er hat angst ein auch in den großen
schritt zu unternehmen das heißt es gibt
viele möglichkeiten wie man diese no fly
zone einrichten könnte nicht nur über
die nato weil dann hat natürlich putin
vielleicht sofort quasi dieses bild dass
feinde sondern auch über die uno zu
versuchen das zu tun mit anderen staaten
die da quasi in einem in einer allianz
der willigen das heißt da gibt es eine
reihe von möglichkeiten hauptsache dass
der politische wille da ist und
anscheinend fällt dieser würde auch
china bilden den eindruck wenn ich das
einmal fragen darf das in der nato von
bestimmten ländern ganz besonders
gebremst wird wir wissen dass von der
bundesregierung sie war eine der letzten
die überhaupt zugestimmt hat das sind
dass waffenlieferungen geben darf das
auch das swift-abkommen
in teilen ausgesetzt wird was ist ihr
eindruck welche regierung bremst derzeit
wenn wir einmal den nato raum anschauen
besonders die total deutschland war
immer das schlusslicht in diesen fragen
in diesem bei diesem thema weiß ich
nicht ich glaube weil auch die
amerikaner die sind natürlich skeptisch
das muss man auch sagen aber in
deutschland dann kann auch eine führende
rolle spielen das ist nicht so dass man
sich immer wieder verstecken musste und
dann erst wenn die anderen so weit sind
ob das swift ausschlüsse oder oder auch
waffenlieferungen ich glaube deutschland
könnte sehr wohl hier eine initiative
starten und sich nicht nur verstecken
und abwarten auf tauchstation gehen das
ist nicht das was die menschen hier
glaube ich erwarte von der regierung
herr männicke swift was sie gerade
angesprochen haben ist ja jetzt passiert
dass china russland aufnimmt ins
verfahren wie viel macht das hat mir
heute mich meine mutter heute morgen
gefragt ehrlich gesagt wie viel macht
haben wir als deutschland überhaupt was
zu verändern wenn dann beispielsweise
china und russland eigentlich gerade
eine verbrüderung vollziehen ich glaube
schon dass das der westen auch seine
machte unterschätzt ja man hat so viel
in der hand vor allem weil weil die
kontakte auch zur china also massiv sind
das heißt man könnte auch aus china
hatten einwirken wenn man sieht dass
china leider wie wir es im moment der
fall ist und den russen in die karten
spielen oder zumindest nicht kritisiert
das was geschieht ja und es geht um
einen vernichtungskrieg gegen die
zivilisten vor allem weil die russen ja
ihr blitzkrieg ist vielleicht noch nicht
ganz gescheitert aber ins stocken
geraten und deswegen rechnen sie sich in
anderen zivilen menschen wie hier in
erbil das ist eine stadt wo viele meiner
freunde häuser haben und einer der
freunde der geflohen ist das haus in der
stadt von worzel also zwei kilometer
weit wurde samt ja es gibt gar nichts ja
alles alles ist weg und deswegen der
westen muss sich besinnen auf seinen
stärken und die stärke liegt vor allem
in den wie in der wirtschaft auch
gegenüber china und schon geil und auf
jeden fall und auch gegenüber russland
und deswegen das thema
embargo worüber wir auch combination
werden ja das ist das ist der größte
trumpf denn die deutschen in der hand
haben und gar nichts spielen und das ist
glaube ich beschämend auf das thema
kommen wir gleich nach zu sprechen ich
möchte nun mit meinem aufreger-thema
starten was ich jetzt schon ehrlich
sagen muss wahrscheinlich jetzt für sie
etwas belanglos wirkung wird nach dieser
wichtigen debatte meine thema heute
abend ist trotzdem die these 3g muss für
alle bürger weg wir finden nachts
verfolgt weiß ja wie wenig verständnis
ich für die meisten krone maßnahmen habe
und mir ist es sehr wichtig dass wir bei
diesem thema auch dranbleiben als
redaktion zweig plus hätte ich niemals
eingeführt werden dürfen von der
einrichtungs beziehungen impfpflicht
ganz zu schweigen und während andere
länder in vielem dem feiern müssen wir
unsere masken tragen schon lange halte
ich vieles für politischen irrsinn doch
heute dachte ich mir wirklich jetzt
spinnen die deutschen was ist passiert
eine gruppe von rund 50 geflüchteten aus
der ukraine die eigentlich nach paris
reisen wollten konnte am samstag
aufgrund einer streckensperrung nicht
weiterreisen und wollte in ein hotel das
war aber nicht möglich der grund kaum
einer aus der gruppe konnte ein 3g
nachweis erbringen darüber berichtete
die stuttgarter zeitung die flüchtlinge
verbrachten die 8 aufgrund des vielen 3g
nachweis in einem warteraum der bahn ich
frage mich schon seit längerem was
wollen wir für ein land sein wie lange
seine menschlichkeit und empathie noch
von impfnachweis abhängig sein und hört
und solidarität mit den flüchtlingen auf
aufgrund eines 3g nachweises das ist
mein thema heute abend weil sich gerne
mit der runde debattieren möchte und ich
würde gerne die frage direkt ein wenig
spielen sie haben die geschichte ja
bestimmt gehört was haben sie da
empfunden dass flüchtlinge nicht ins
hotel durfte aufgrund eines 3g
nachweises ja dass nur traurig denn wir
sind dankbar für diese
warme aufnahme von vielen vielen
menschen das sind schon zehntausende die
in deutschland angekommen sind aus der
ukraine hunderttausend in polen und es
ist erstaunlich dass das nur weil eben
diese formalitäten da ist dass die
menschen gar keinen zugang zu seinen
kosten oder zu einem hotel haben das
kann man nur schwer vorstellen verstehen
wenn man bedenkt dass diese menschen
einen weg hinter sich zurück gelegt
haben der mann keine so was wünschen
würde und wenn man überlegt dass in
einen anderen ländern auch nicht so wäre
also nicht in einer dass vor allem
kinder und frauen sind ja weil die
männer die bleiben und viele kinder sind
auch allein unterwegs weil auch mütter
die heimat nicht verlassen konnte und
das ist schon krass was dann geschieht
herr kuban wir sind sie das denn mit der
deutschen innenpolitik in zukunft wir
haben jetzt bei den flüchtlingen nicht
nur die problematik mit dem 3g nachweis
die impfquote ist ja auch wesentlich
geringer als in deutschland in der
ukraine wie soll deutschland da in
zukunft vorgehen
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich war
letzte woche auch an der polnisch
ukrainischen grenze viele von den
menschen dort gesehen von gerade den
müttern mit kindern die sich auf den weg
gemacht haben und
ehrlicherweise
bedrückt mich das leid was ich dort
gesehen habe ein bisschen mehr als
unsere oder 3g regeln der zeitweilig
auch ganz offen und ehrlich sage ich
erwarte dass dort unbürokratische
lösungen gefunden werden aber natürlich
weiß ich auch dass momentan bei mir in
der region hannover mit 1,2 millionen
einwohnern nur irgendwie 120 leute
hospitalisiert sind und man kann über
alle streiten aber wir dürfen jetzt die
themen aus meiner sicht auch nicht
vermischen mir geht es darum dass wir
das leid in der ukraine bekämpfen dass
wir dafür sorgen dass wladimir putin
diesen grausamen krieg beendet und dass
er möglichst nicht mehr länger präsident
der russischen föderation ist das ist
mein ziel aber das andere thema rückt
für mich ziemlich in den hintergrund und
wir dürfen die sachen jetzt nicht
vermischen wenn ich jetzt teilweise auch
solche tweets von ralf stegner lese wir
müssen uns jetzt auf die unsere
ressourcen auf den klimawandel
beschränkt und dürften deswegen keinen
krieg führen dann ist das total absurd
und läuft irgendwie alles in die falsche
richtung deswegen finde ich wir sollten
den fokus auf die ukraine lenken und wie
wir helfen können
also ich weiß mir fällt ehrlich gesagt
die worte bei so einem bayerischen ja
auch der botschafter hat gerade gesagt
wenn man 48 stunde unterwegs ist ja auch
vielleicht nur noch das nötigste er am
leib trägt was man überhaupt besessen
hat alles zurückgelassen hat vielleicht
sogar weiß dass das haus oder die
wohnung zerstört ist dann in ein freies
land kommt das land sagt nee du darfst
hier nicht in einem normalen bett
schlafen weil die der test oder dein
impfausweis fehlt dann glaube ich kann
man auch den glauben an die freiheit
ganz schnell wieder verlieren mein
eindruck ist überhaupt über die
vergangenen jahre dass wir in
deutschland es sehr gut gelernt haben
uns in einem regel korsett extrem gut zu
bewegen aber in diesem regel korsett zu
bleiben und bloß nicht rauszugehen sagt
haben uns angewöhnt weil viele dinge
einfach nicht gut laufen stichwort
ausrüstung der bundeswehr und dann war
es viel wichtiger in afghanistan
beispielsweise dass die mülltrennung
funktioniert hat in den camps in denen
die bundeswehr war das erzählen ja die
soldaten immer wieder gerne wenn sie
zurückgekommen sind oder die die da
waren dass alle die mülltrennung extrem
wichtig waren hat man gesehen wie die
afghanen am ende wenn sie den müll aus
der blauen der braunen der gelben und
der grauen tonne abgeholt haben hinter
dem camp einfach zusammen geschmissen
haben also die müssten sonst was sie nur
sagen will ist dieser regel irrsinn der
sich da bei uns in vielerlei hinsicht
manchmal bahn bricht der trifft jetzt
auf eine wirklichkeit und es ist
eigentlich beschämend dass menschen die
alles zurückgelassen haben und dem tod
wahrscheinlich ganz knapp entronnen sind
jetzt nicht in einem normalen weichen
bett schlafen können weil sie
möglicherweise ihren impfausweis auf der
flucht verloren haben da fehlen mir die
worte
mir auch und dementsprechend bin ich
trotzdem froh auch wenn herr koban dass
er als etwas belangloses gerade also
angesichts des leides muss man wirklich
sagen also das was man momentan sieht
was wir heute wieder für bilder gesehen
haben was wir dort vor ort sehen da
erwarte ich einfach dass es eine
unbürokratische lösung gibt und das hat
für mich jetzt auch weniger mit regel
ihr sind zu tun muss ich auch ganz offen
und ehrlich gestehen sondern glaube dass
es da wesentliche probleme gibt die wir
lösen müssen und vor ort dann einfach
auch mal ein bisschen mit einem auge das
ganze erst der menschenverstand walten
kommen wir nun zu einem weiteren thema
heute abend und weil das von andré wenig
was ernst mitgebracht hat es geht um öl
und gas und ob wir die importe
stoppen soll
ja das ist nach wie vor die schärfste
waffe die deutschen aber auch die die eu
hat in der hand gegenüber herrn putin
wir oder die deutschen und die europäer
zahlen pro tag
in die kriegskasse von herrn punkten
knapp eine milliarde euro und wenn man
bedenkt dass das das haushalt das
militärische haushalte russlands knapp
60 milliarden euro pro jahr beträgt dann
kann man sich ausrechnen dass das in
zwei monaten
hatten russland wieder ein
neunmeter um diesen krieg fortzusetzen
noch weitere sechs jahre innerhalb eines
jahres in der man für die gas
lieferungen nach russland zahlt und
deswegen glauben wir schon das dass die
bundesregierung die immer wieder jetzt
eine ablehnende haltung eingenommen hat
dass diese position schnellstens
geändert werden muss denn wenn wir schon
mit sanktionen mit diesen mechanismen
agieren dann glaube ich schon es wäre
eine sünde die diese größte waffe die
man hat das ist eine keule das ist es
wirklich das dass das womit man
vielleicht auch diesen krieg beenden
kann und zwar sehr schnell dass man
diese keule nicht benutzt gegenüber den
pudding und deswegen wollen wir auch an
die bundesregierung appellieren an die
deutschen und die deutschen unterstützen
übrigens über die hälfte der deutschen
glaubt umfragen würden diesen schritt
befürworten aber die regierung stellt
sich weil man eben sich sorgen macht um
den sozialen zusammenhalt und das kann
man verstehen als ukraine aber wenn man
die bilder sieht das was jetzt bei uns
los ist eine hülle los ein entfernung
auf erden und das muss man auch noch im
verhältnis sehen das was heute morgen
unternommen werden könnte und sollte
hier in deutschland das könnte tausende
menschenleben retten in der ukraine ganz
konkret und das ist auch nach wie vor
unsere bitte an die bundesregierung an
die menschen hier in diesem schon im
land zu helfen und diese meinung zu
ernten so schnell wie möglich ich glaube
es ja mal ganz wichtigen punkt gemacht
weil sie von einem scharfen schwert
gesprochen haben und ich glaube wir
können schon verstehen dass die
westliche welt extrem eng zusammensteht
dass putin das gegenteil von dem
erreicht hat was er eigentlich wollte
den westen zu dividieren nein das
gegenteil ist passiert und
ich glaube dass der krieg den putin der
angezettelt hat ohnehin teuer wird so
oder so für den westen sei es durch
waffenlieferung sei es durch ein
militärisches eingreifen oder sei es
eben dadurch dass man sagt okay wir
stoppen mit dem über morgigen tage oder
anfang nächster woche alle importe die
wir haben in sachen gas und öl das wird
natürlich vorübergehend zu einem
dramatischen weiteren anstieg von gas-
und ölpreisen führen das ist richtig
aber die frage ist aber welche kosten
sind da zu schultern und welche kosten
wären zu schultern wenn dieser krieg
noch lange lange weitergeht und die
russischen armee möglicherweise bis an
die polnische grenze voran kommen oder
vielleicht sogar darüber hinaus das
wären kosten da hat man sich gar
eingeschlafen und von daher ist glaub
immer sich da ein punkt zu sagen lage
weg sofort heime import einhaken gerne
ein sehr wenig es hat ja bislang haben
die sanktion ja noch nicht gezeigt dass
sie dabei helfen den krieg aufzuhalten
und man hat natürlich die sanktion als
abschreckungs mechanismus aber wenn wir
jetzt schon jede abschreckung in einen
ball machen in dieses schwert und
draufhauen haben wir kaum noch
abschreckung also irgendwie sind ja alle
unsere mittel erst mal weg also woran
sehen wir denn bislang dass vladimir
putin auf die sanktionen so reagiert
dass er den krieg beenden wird er hat
diese sanktionen die schon heute
eingeführt wurden einkalkuliert er
wusste ganz genau was auf ihn zukommen
könnte
das war in seiner kalkulation ganz
bestimmt zwölf zum beispiel war
womöglich nicht dabei das heißt beim
swift müsste man dann nachlegen und all
die banken ausschließen nicht nur die
sieben jetzt betroffen sind das heißt
auch die größte die sberbank die
gazprombank über diese zahlungen für
gaslieferungen
erfolgen all die anderen banken das
würde wirklich eine enorme wirkung
erzeugen und das zweite
nämlich dieses embargo man könnte auch
mit einem moratorium versuchen ein monat
wird kein gas kein öl keine kohle wird
gekauft und dann schauen das heißt auch
dass man man die besten haben so viele
möglichkeiten in der hand und die werden
kaum genutzt man wartet ab man man man
hat angst dass das vielleicht eine
gegenreaktion
sie kostet geld ja wir sehen ja aber
schon auch das was man an berichten aus
russland hört sieht bilder die man sieht
dass die sanktionen durchaus wirkung
zeigen irgendwann merkte sind leer es
gibt die schlangen an automaten
automaten spucken nur noch einen ganz
ganz kleinen teil maximal 8000 rubel aus
also 68 euro umgerechnet die man abheben
kann täglich also da wird schon massiv
rationalisiert bei putin weiß die
sanktionen treffen ihn und sein land
extrem hart wir hören dass
möglicherweise weil die flugzeuge nicht
mehr gewartet werden die flugzeug linien
wie beispielsweise aeroflot vielleicht
noch zwei vielleicht noch drei wochen
überhaupt fliegen können dann müssten
die am boden bleiben weil sie nicht mehr
gewartet werden bzw und auch am samstag
also ein land einer eröffnung
wahrscheinlich in den kompletten absturz
gerät gehören von ökonomen die sagen sie
rechnen mit einem absturz der
wirtschaftsleistung um 35 prozent in
russland das sind dramatische zahlen
klar und dann ist die frage begehrt eine
bevölkerung auf ganz klar ist für putin
wird es wenn das sich alles durch setzt
zumindest im land extrem ungemütlich
paul ich für dich an dieser stelle gerne
reinholen keiner ist so nagl du gerade
in kiew direkt vor ort was sagst du
kriegst unsere diskussionen mit sollten
wir sollte deutschland die öl- und
gasimporte stoppen wie ist die stimmung
vor ort wird es ein aufbegehren auch in
russland gegen putin irgendwann geben
deutschland sollte dieses embargo sofort
verhängen aus meiner sicht wir können es
mit unseren werten nicht vereinbaren mit
unseren mit unserer moral die wir gerne
als deutsche vor uns hertragen mit dem
wir auf die welt blicken wie wir dinge
analysieren wie wir dinge kritisieren
jetzt ist die stunde gekommen jetzt
müssen uns beweisen in einem moment wo
zivilisten mit raketen ermordet werden
wo ganze städte in schutt und asche
gelegt werden mario polywka chief wie
kinder frauen angegriffen werden wie
nichts mehr wirklich gar nichts mehr
heilig ist heute stand ich vor einer
fast komplett zerstörten kirche da kann
es doch nicht unser ernst sein dass wir
jetzt sagen aus sorge vor einer
wirtschaftlichen verlust aus sorge dafür
dass dann
probleme gibt
dass wir das nicht tun das ist für mich
völlig unverständlich und ich kann nur
hoffen dass es genauso wie bei swift
sein wird denn da hat sich der
bundeskanzler auch zunächst gesperrt
auch in den wochen vorher ist immer nein
swift das geht ja gar nicht zu
kompliziert doch es geht das sehen wir
und das andere geht natürlich auch und
nur diese sprache versteht wladimir
putin und diese sprache wenn es schon
keine flugverbotszone gibt wenn wir hier
schon nicht
eingreifen können dann doch zumindest
dass die schärfsten sanktionen die die
welt jemals gesehen hat und eine ganz
klare sprache es geht keine minute mehr
dass dieser krieg weitergeht aber wie
viel bringen uns die sanktion wenn china
nicht mitziehen das ist ja schon die
gefahr gerade da der china und russland
immer immer enger zusammen werden und
dann wir nicht wirklich erklären können
das sollte uns erstmal egal sein das
können wir nicht beeinflussen natürlich
ist es richtig dass china wichtig ist
das ist alles richtig auf der anderen
seite zeigt sich dass die ukraine gerade
die freiheit des westens verteidigt denn
wenn die ukraine sich sofort ergeben
hätten nach zwei oder drei tagen wenn
dieses militär nicht so stehen würde
wenn die moral nicht so groß wäre hier
im ganzen land dann wäre das ja nur der
anfang denn hätte russland gesehen acht
wir können schnell einmarschieren und
wir übernehmen mein land und wer ist als
nächstes dran das gleiche t china
gedacht und gesagt ja dann versuchen wir
doch mal in taiwan da wird sicherlich
auch nichts passiert also die ukraine
jeder einzelne mensch der hier gerade an
der front steht verteidigt unsere
freiheit und so ganz persönliche
freiheit und auch unsere ganz
persönliche sicherheit das ist ganz
wichtig zu sagen und was die sanktionen
angeht wir können natürlich versuchen
auch china einfluss zu nehmen das ist
auch wichtig aber am ende stehen wir für
unsere eigene regierung für unsere
eigenen kurs und unabhängig davon was
china macht sollten wir als deutsche
klar blicken und klar sein und klar
schauen und wenn man sieht dass hier
hinter mir in demnächst die raketen rein
hageln können wie in mario pohl wir
aktiv wie in ihre pin ruhig war dann
müssen wir doch sagen wie können wir
noch einen einzigen tag russisches öl
und gas importieren
ich glaube ist am 1 man muss sagen es
geht nur eins wir brauchen dann kann ich
beides verweigert man kann nicht
verweigern harte sanktion und man kann
nicht verweigern wir liefern waffen also
es gibt mindestens eins muss man
aufgeben wenn ich das einmal muss sagen
dass paul auch vollkommen richtig die
bundesregierung kann ich sagen wir
wollen das eigentlich und das andere
auch nicht zählt nicht ja wir brauchen
am ende ein embargo wir brauchen auch
vor allem ein ölembargo war da das
substitut für uns oder die alternative
für uns etwas einfacher ist wir brauchen
das aber europäische und amerikanische
und wir brauchen es gemeinsam mit den
amerikanern und den europäern weil herr
botschafter sie haben eben gerade auch
die zahlen genannt das ist das scharfe
schwert deutschland alleine ist viel
aber das scharfe schwert ist wenn wir es
als amerikaner und als europäer
gemeinsam machen und die muss auch sagen
da fand ich es auch zu wenig was ich
gehört habe von der reise von robert
habeck was er am ende dort auch aus
amerika mitgebracht hatte ich finde es
gut dass heute ja auch us-außenminister
blinken das ganze thema in der
europäischen union mit denen ministern
und mit dem mit der kommission
diskutiert hat von daher ist es wir sind
auf diesem weg und ich kann die deutsche
bundesregierung nur ermutigen diesen weg
weiter zu pushen wir müssen diesen weg
gehen aber wirklich stark im markt im
weltmarkt sind wir wenn wir als westen
gemeinsam als europäer und als
amerikaner gemeinsam agieren mit dieser
kleinen rede am ende von tilman kuban
geben wir jetzt eine ganz kurze
unterbrechung wir bleiben alle hier paul
ronzheimer bleibt hier besprechen gleich
auch über die innenpolitik und den
koalitionsvertrag bis gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück liebe
zuschauer bei 48 und wir machen direkt
weiter mit der these von politik chef
jan schäfer ja die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer die bundesregierung die
ampelkoalition ist noch nicht einmal 100
tage im amt und meiner meinung nach ist
der koalitionsvertrag der abgeschlossen
wurde aber eigentlich nur noch schrott
denn er stammt aus einer anderen zeit
damals im jahr 20 21 war der ukraine
krieg noch relativ weit fern man hatte
immer noch die hoffnung dass putin nicht
so weit gehen würde mir gegangen ist und
man hat sich überlegt zwischen spd
grünen und fdp so wirklich
herausforderte dinge wie eine ausweitung
der elternzeit viele viele sozial
geschenke beispielsweise auch an die
rentner
bezahlten urlaub zwei wochen bezahlten
urlaub für junge väter all das soll der
staat soll die allgemeinheit bezahlen es
gibt wahnsinnig viele förderprogramme
auch für klimaschutz der natürlich total
wichtig ist aber auch da die frage wird
das geld immer richtig eingesetzt ich
glaube die bundesregierung die ampel
koalition muss komplett neu denken der
krieg den wir sehen muss dazu führen
dass viele dinge im haushalt komplett
umgeschichtet werden noch viel stärker
hinrichtung bundeswehr auch richtung
verteidigung und vor allem richtung
entlastung der bürger und entlastung der
wirtschaft denn das was uns hier droht
auch durch den krieg das wird eine neue
rezession vielleicht sogar eine
depression sein das heißt weg mit dem
alten koalitionsvertrag wir brauchen
einen neustart wir brauchen ein völlig
neues papier dame
paul es gibt weniger beziehungsweise
niemanden den ich kenne der
innenpolitisch und außenpolitisch seiner
expertise hat wenn du jetzt dazu gehört
dass bei der these ich hoffe die
verbindung war gut genug er würde dem
zustimmen muss ein neuer
koalitionsvertrag her und falls ja was
sollte jetzt auch explizit mit blick auf
den krieg drin stehen
neuer koalitionsvertrag den solltest
geben vor allem sollte es ein
gipfeltreffen geben finde ich zwischen
den drei parteien und da komme ich
sozusagen wieder auf die ursprungs these
die debatte zurück des embargos ich
glaube dass annalena baerbock und
christian lindner die fdp steht für die
freiheit so zu sagen annalena baerbock
partei stand schon lange für einen
schärferen kurs gegenüber russland dass
die beiden jetzt die verantwortung haben
olaf scholz einzufangen und zu sagen das
machen wir nicht mit nicht länger diese
positionierung nicht länger in unserem
land eine positionierung die dazu führt
dass wir putins kriegskasse füllen und
deswegen ist es völlig richtig ein neuer
koalitionsvertrag und insbesondere ein
gipfeltreffen und zwar sofort wo
christian lindner und annalena baerbock
klar sagen diese politik die ihr
jahrelang mit angela merkel führen
konnte diese politik die geprägt ist aus
putin liebe und aus schröder zeiten die
ist ein für alle mal vorbei und
insbesondere so lange vorbei wie
wladimir putin hier einen grausamen
krieg führt also anna lena berger und
christian lindner müssen jetzt olaf
scholz anfangen
also ich würd ich bin jetzt nicht
berater der koalition das muss die
koalition schon selbst entscheiden ob
sie neuen koalitionsvertrag braucht aber
mir wäre es ehrlicher weise lieber sie
würden jetzt in dieser krise sehr
schnell und konsequent handeln wir haben
das gesehen bei den lieferungen die ich
vorhin angesprochen habe wie lange das
gedauert hat wir sehen das wie das mit
der kontaktaufnahme der ukraine dauert
ich muss ihn schon gesagt hat mich
geschämt als ich gesehen habe wie wie
der präsident des ski emanuel makro
gedankt hat und wie wir da gestanden
haben wird wie bedröppelte pudel da da
wünsche ich mir das jetzt konkret
gehandelt wird und wir können jetzt viel
darüber diskutieren dass wir ein
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
brauchen wir können viel darüber
diskutieren dass wir uns auf diese neue
sicherheitslage ein
so ein spiel müssen aber mir geht es
jetzt darum dass wir schnellstmöglich
den ukrainerinnen und ukrainer die jeden
tag unter dauerbeschuss dieses kranken
mannes stehen dass wir denen helfen und
im neuen koalitionsvertrag das kann
jetzt auch noch mal ein paar wochen
warten beider liebe er gewann aber sie
sehen ja auch was dafür nicht eine frage
ja
ich habe eine frage an den kubanern die
mir schon vorher den kopf kam weil sie
gesagt haben dass putin sozusagen weg
muss sind sie der überzeugung wie
lindsay graham der republikanische
abgeordnete den usa de gesagt hat jemand
muss putin erschießen jemand muss putin
ermorden
das ist eine ganz ganz schwierige
geschichte man wünscht glaube ich
niemanden den tod auch wenn in diesen
tagen ein wahnsinniger hass und eine
wahnsinnige wut auf diese person
herrscht ich weiß nicht ob das am ende
das ganze beendet ich sage nur wladimir
putin darf nie wieder einen fuß auf ein
anderes land dieser welt setzen er darf
noch einmal dass ich darf noch ein nein
das ist nicht allein lösen er darf ja
zeit können die sie da sagt herren
zweimal darf noch ein einziges mal ein
anderes land betreten und das ist in den
haag vor dem internationalen
strafgerichtshof
das muss das ziel sein
und ich kann mir das vollkommen ich kann
es vollkommen nachvollziehen dass viele
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer so denken ich
kann es mir auch durchaus vorstellen
dass viele menschen in deutschland so
denken und sagen eigentlich müsste einer
jetzt so wie stauffenberg versucht hat
das ganze auch bei putin tun aber ich
persönlich sage für mich steht die würde
des menschen immer noch an erster stelle
und auch wenn ich diesen hass und diese
wut auf diese person nachvollziehen kann
unser ziel muss es sein dass er am ende
vor dem internationalen strafgerichtshof
in den haag steht
ist die antwort völlig ausreichend paul
absolut ich habe es verstanden nur zu
sagen dass
wladimir putin also ich meine er
erbringt halt jeden tag menschen um ja
und das passiert halt jetzt in diesem
moment
deswegen ist die frau wie ist er zu
stoppen und ich glaube
ja also ich würde da auch die in die
antwort von von anderen meldet
interessieren wie er das sieht und wie
er das bewertet was der amerikanische
abgeordnete lindsay graham gesagt ja es
gibt viele optionen natürlich haben wir
das geschehen könnte einen putsch ganz
oben könnte nicht ausgeschlossen werden
denn auch die clique herum um den podien
herum sie kann auch nicht umhin
umzusehen also diesen freien fall der
wirtschaft auch der gesellschaft und
deswegen ein volksaufstand wäre auch
denkbar möglich aber vielleicht nicht
gleich nur wenn die menschen tatsächlich
spüren die diese folgen der sanktionen
die truppen könnten auch versorgen das
ist schon heute man man darf auch das
nicht aus den augen verlieren dass dass
die soldaten die er massenweise in den
tod geschickt in der ukraine sind nach
unseren angaben über 11.000 tote
soldaten die ihr ende im boden der
ukraine gefunden haben ich meine und das
sehen auch die anderen das heißt es gibt
viele faktoren die jetzt auch eine
gewisse wirkung entfalten könnten und um
diesen krieg zu beenden aber für uns für
mich ist wichtig und ich darf vielleicht
ganz kurz zurück zum thema
koalitionsvertrag zurückkommen es steht
dort im dokument ein thema eu und der
ukraine sehr sehr schwierig formuliert
und heute das wissen wir mein präsident
salewski wo ich jetzt immer noch ist er
hat nicht nur jetzt waffen um waffen
gebeten er hat auch das thema auf den
tisch gelegt dass die ukraine zumindest
jetzt dieser eu-weites perspektive
bekommt und wir hoffen dass die
deutschen das unterstützen die ampel
regierung stemmt sich leider also die
antwort bis heute war können wir nicht
machen und es kann durchaus sein dass
dem land das verbot wird tag und nacht
wo menschen fliehen müssen hoffentlich
nur vorläufig auch nach deutschland das
diesem land diese perspektive
weggenommen wird also die menschen die
fliehen die brauchen eine zukunft wir
brauchen zuversicht dass sie auch bald
zurückkommen und dieses lang gemeinsam
aufbauen darum geht es und deswegen
wollen wir auch die deutschen
appellieren die unterstützen diese eine
mehrheit der deutschen wäre auch dafür
dass die ukraine nicht heute und nicht
in fünf jahren aber vielleicht in zehn
jahren auch teil dieser familie wird
darum geht es und das ist ganz ganz
wichtig es wird viel über die frage des
eu-beitritts gesprochen es geht nicht
darum dass die ukraine von heute auf
morgen einfach so teil der europäischen
union ist sondern es geht darum die
beitrittsverhandlungen zu starten zwei
geht es perspektive wir haben
mittlerweile auch die europäische union
es geht jetzt auch kokain geht ja das
muss man leider sagen auch als ein
korruptes land ist sie bereit union also
wir haben begonnen unsere hausaufgaben
im jahre 2014 zu machen wir haben einen
assoziierungsabkommen und ich war in der
regierung ein jahr lang nach dem mann
und meine einzige aufgabe bestand darin
damit dass die ukrainischen behörden
dieses dokument das ist
1200 seiten dick dass wir das umsetzen
wir sind ziemlich gut also im plan im
zeitplan wenn wir bis zum jahre 25 wie
es steht fertig sind dann stünden wir
nicht schlechter oder sogar besser da
als die letzten kandidaten länder
rumänien und bulgarien die beigetreten
sind das heißt wir machen unsere
hausaufgaben das ist nicht so dass wir
irgendwo ganz hinten in der reihe stehen
und plötzlich nach vorne wollen nein wir
wissen worum es geht es kommt darauf an
dass diese politische entscheidung heute
gleich in berlin getroffen wird und dann
dieser weg der verhandlungsweg geöffnet
wird und dann werde ich schauen wenn wir
scheitern dann haben wir keine chance
wenn wir wenn wir erfolge zeigen wir
jetzt in diesem krieg wo wir bestehen wo
wir die menschen auf der ganzen welt
überrascht haben mit dem mut mit der
endlichkeit wir könnten auch die
europäer auf die deutschen auch die
ampel überraschend dass wir auch da ganz
schnell vorankommen kann ich finde da
nicht aber frau schenk noch kurz am ende
muss man wirklich sagen die ukraine ist
in einer ganz besonderen situation wie
wir es seit vielen vielen jahrzehnten
auf europäischem boden nicht erlebt
haben und deswegen muss man ihn jetzt
eine perspektive bieten ich weiß dass
das auch bei mir in meiner partei sehr
kontrovers diskutiert aber ich halte es
für richtig es geht und das hat der
botschaft eben gerade noch mal sehr
deutlich gesagt es geht nicht darum
heute zu entscheiden ist die ukraine
mitglied in der europäischen union
sondern starten wir ein prozess der in
den nächsten 5 110 jahren ab und das
wäre ein starkes zeichen was von berlin
aus gesendet werden muss nicht kann das
zögern der ampel an dieser stelle nicht
verstehen und damit würde ich sagen
kommen wir direkt sich aber gemischt
ich frage mich eine sache wie kann wie
kann irgendein politiker in dieser
regierung in deutschland ist noch mit
dem gewissen vereinbaren diese dinge
abzulehnen ich
schauen doch auch nachrichten die sehen
doch die bilder zu sehen doch was wir
berichten und wie kann man denn der
ukraine in so einer phase verweigern er
zumindest zu rücken an die europäische
union noch mal wenige kilometer hier wo
ich gerade bin entfernt haben 2014 die
menschen mit einer europäischen flagge
demonstriert und diese menschen da
demonstriert haben die sind jetzt an der
front und die sind dort an der front
weil sie europäische werte verteidigt
und was machen unsere politiker die
sagen naja mal abwarten man darf den
putin nicht provozieren schauen wir mal
ich hab da kaum noch worte für
das geht genau darum und sammer man darf
putin nicht mit der angst begegnen wenn
deutsche außenpolitik wenn europäische
außenpolitik oder außenpolitik des
westens nur mit der angst vorangeht dann
kann man am ende wladimir putin nicht
besiegen das ist die wahrheit und
deswegen müssen wir wieder zu
selbstbewusstsein zu stärken kommen als
europäer als westen insgesamt das
wünsche ich mir eigentlich und das pushe
ich auch in der nächsten generation und
damit kommen wir direkt zu ihrem thema
kuban
ja was mein thema ist ich engagiere mich
jetzt seit einer woche mit unserer
aktion helden helfen dafür dass die so
genannten land verteidiger in der
ukraine besser ausgestattet werden wir
haben momentan wir haben die situation
es gibt die erste reihe wo die
soldatinnen und soldaten der
ukrainischen armee stehen und die zweite
reihe die freiwilligen leute die einfach
ein gewehr in die hand bekommen haben
und als freiwillige als land verteidiger
dort so nennen sie zur verfügung stehen
und gegen die schweren geschütze der
russischen armee kämpfen und ich muss
sagen ich wünsche mir dass auch diese
menschen gerade viele kommen aus unseren
jugendorganisationen viele mit denen ich
persönlich befreundet bin dass sie
besser ausgestattet werden deswegen
sollte der bund und die länder mehr
schutzwesten liefern es sollten mehr
schutzkleidung geliefert werden wir als
junge union haben die aktion gestartet
und haben dort schon einigen den ersten
konvoi hingebracht der zweite ist gerade
auf dem weg und es braucht dringend für
diese leute mehr unterstützung weil sie
sind den angriffen artillerie oder auch
sprengsätzen einfach schutzlos
ausgeliefert dafür setze ich mich allen
das fordere ich von der bundes und von
den landesregierungen
wenig wie empfinden sie die sagt ich
kann mich nur anschließen denn das was
herr gruber noch gesehen hatten gespürt
hat es kommt darauf an dass die über
100.000
menschen die sich jetzt freiwillig
gemeldet haben um das land zu
verteidigen
sie bekommen zwar ein maschinengewehr
ein kalaschnikow in der hand gedrückt
und dann eine kurze schulung aber an
schutzwesten
feldes helme und andere ausrüstung weil
das natürlich nicht im budget vorgesehen
weil wir haben uns nicht auf einen krieg
vorbereitet der mehr ist mehr oder
weniger gut gerüstet aber nicht all die
menschen die jetzt da am blog posten
stehen die versuchen auch diese
sabotagen gruppen zu vernichten und das
sind auch meine freunde also botschafter
die noch vor kurzem hier in europa tätig
waren schicken mir bilder sie haben auch
ein maschinengewehr sie stellen oder sie
kontrollieren die straßen in danach so
sieht der alltag aus heute in der
ukraine mitten in europa und deswegen
danke vielmals hermann für für dieser
initiative wir hoffen dass auch die
bundesregierung dass die länder uns
unterstützen es fehlt ist ein mangelware
muss man sagen schon sichere westen ist
wirklich eine mangelware geld ist zwar
da aber das zu finden ist nicht so
einfach und aber jede schutzweste zählte
und ich habe gerade vorgestern einen
anruf bekommen aus mit cholera auf einen
start im süden sie ist umzingelt und
und der bürgermeister ruft verzweifelt
brauche 3000 schutzwesten weil sonst ich
die stadt nicht verteidigen kann weil
die hre gedruckt vorliegen und das ist
alltag der menschen heute wenn wir mit
ihnen sprechen und die leute müssen
auswahl und in der kälte es kommt schnee
und sie brauchen diese unterstützung aus
deutschland deswegen vielen dank und
deswegen glaube ich auch wir müssen bei
uns die polizei bestände prüfen und wir
müssen auch da den da bin ich wirklich
beim regel ihr sind ich habe in den
letzten tagen einige gespräche geführt
da sagen mir leute wir haben
ausgemusterte westen in deutschland die
sind ausgemustert weil man nicht mehr
für die sicherheit garantieren kann dort
sind menschen komplett schutzlosen da
kann es doch nicht mehr um ausgemustert
gehen da müssen die sachen hin und die
wollen leute in deutschland diese diese
westen vernichten weil sie ausgemustert
sind das wäre einfach die mein kopf rein
muss ich wirklich sagen da müssen wir
dringend und schnell handeln ich
bewundere das was thema kuban macht mit
seiner aktion wir bei bild herz für
kinder ist ja auch eine
organisation die extrem jetzt hilft aber
ich frage mich herr botschafter welt
gehöre auch ihre schilderungen sind sie
eigentlich manchmal selbst überrascht
über den kampfesmut ihrer landsleute
oder haben sie erwartet dass die so
reagieren wenn putin kommt und ich hatte
keine zweifel dass ich die deutschen
haben immer noch zweifel an uns das ist
das was ich auch hier sind politische
berlin der zwölfte tag des krieges und
man räumt uns immer noch kaum eine
chance dass wir diesen krieg überleben
können dass wir nicht verlieren und wir
dürfen diesen krieg nicht verlieren und
deswegen das was an uns liegt wir werden
alles tun und da wird gekämpft auch wenn
es vielleicht keine waffen mehr gibt
dann wenn wir das verlieren wenn wir
unsere heimat verlieren dann wird sie
nicht mehr zu gewinnen kann dann dann
werden menschen verjagt menschen
gefoltert menschen im kz geschichte
ähnlich wie in belarus wie in russland
selbst das wollen wir nicht und deswegen
es geht um das schiere überleben als
staat als volk und deswegen stellt sich
auch die frage gar nicht ob wir uns
wehren oder nicht manche würden
vielleicht schon uns wünschen okay wir
können diese schreckliche bilder gar
nicht mehr ertragen das was wir sehen
aber dann gefallen werden wir nicht und
die deutschen diese bilder nicht mehr
sehen weil wir uns nicht erlauben können
einfach so stoppt und zu sagen okay ein
kompromiss machen das geht nicht putin
will keine kompromisse er will die
ukraine besetzen und vernichten und
darum geht es und deswegen auch in
unserer strophe der hymne die erste
strophe heißt noch ist die ukraine nicht
gestorben das heißt es ist so man man
kämpft weil das eigentliche teil der dna
der ukraine ist zu kämpfen weil wir
unsere staatlichkeit viel zu oft
verlieren mussten und wir dürfen das
heute nichts tun wir dürfen die heimat
nicht verlieren und ich glaube wir
sollten uns schon auch jeder der in
deutschland der daran zweifelt ob wir zu
viel tun ob wir im endeffekt zu viel
sanktionen auch die natürlich auch als
bumerang zu nach deutschland
zurückkommen jeder der meint es wäre
falsch dass wir waffen auch in die
ukraine liefert der sollte sich eine
frage stellen nämlich die frage während
wir eigentlich auch so mutig werden wir
eigentlich auch bereit unser land so in
diesem maße zu verteidigen wie das
diejenigen in der ukraine
unsere freundinnen und freunde gerade
tun und nur wer diese frage mit ja
beantwortet der darf weiter kritik üben
aus meiner sicht ist dann habe ich auch
die umkehr frage herr kuban wer auch
bereit wäre das zu tun ist für alle
sanktionen auf die verbotszone und allem
drum und dran was damit mitschwingt am
ende ist es eine abwägungsfrage und ich
habe ja schon gesagt wir sind da auch
nicht alleine auf dieser im westen wir
sind ein wesentlicher teil des westens
aber der westen kann nur gemeinsam
agieren und wir müssen am ende für eine
notlösung genauso wie auch für andere
maßnahmen wie auch für die frage des
embargos wenn es wirklich richtig
hilfreich sein soll dann müssen wir
dafür eben die anderen partner wie die
europäische union und wie auch die
amerikaner an unserer seite haben das
gehört zur wahrheit einfach dazu die
deutschen können das bewegen die
deutschen können einen prozess pushen
das haben wir in der vergangenheit sie
haben das thema swift vorhin
angesprochen der botschafter zu wenig
getan da waren wir eher zögerlich ich
hielte das für falsch
und wir sollten bei dieser stelle mehr
voranschreiten aber wir müssen es
gemeinsam mit den europäischen partnern
und amerikanern tun nur so ist es
wirksam ein mann bei dem ich weiß dass
seine worte nicht nur worte sind sondern
dass er den auch wirklich taten folgen
lassen würde je nachdem wie putin sich
entscheidet ist paul ronzheimer und
deswegen möchte ich die sendung gerne
wieder in alter tradition mit dir auch
beenden und den schilderungen von deinem
heutigen kriegstag und was du erlebt
hast
janina das was ich heute in ihre pin dem
vorort von kiel sehen konnte ist etwas
was auf die ganze ukraine zurollt
nämlich eine komplette zerstörung eine
vernichtung des lebens menschen die ihre
häuser verlassen müssen menschen die
freunde familie kinder verlieren
menschen die schon auf der flucht waren
die ein gepäckstück dabei hatten auf der
straße waren die von einer rakete putins
getroffen werden
wie deutsche dürfen da nicht einfach
zuschauen aus meiner sicht wir müssen
endlich verstehen was dort passiert und
so handeln jeder tag an dem wir nichts
tun an dem die sanktion lasch sind
machen wir uns mitschuldig mit dem was
ich hier sehe und die menschen gehen
gerade jetzt ins bett ist es eine
geister stimmung es ist ruhiger als
sonst das macht aber viele nervös weil
alle wissen putin wird nicht aufhören
damit zumindest nicht so wird nicht
aufhören hier die menschen zu
bombardieren er wird nicht aufhören das
sirenengeheul in allen städten der
ukraine zu hören ist und er wird nicht
aufhören zivilisten zu bombardieren denn
das ist ein ziel angst und terror zu
verbreiten und da will die ukraine dazu
bringen dass sie als staat nicht mehr
existent ist und das was ich hier heute
in der pin in kiew erlebt habe droht in
vielen städten und passiert in vielen
städten den haag tief in anderen in
allen großen der ukraine ich kann nur
unsere zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
bitten schauen sie weiterhin schauen sie
was hier passiert
dem ist nichts hinzuzufügen paar wir
möchten die sendung so beenden schönen
abend noch und bis morgen
[Musik]